finally tonight today is national dog  biscuit day here is some video of our  pooch is getting some treats uh that's  milo uh producer brooke's dog and then  we have uh  oh boy we have denise's crew yeah whole  crew oliver penny  and louie that's him with the orange  ears this is your dog that's my dog  susie coming running for a treat earlier  today  and then we have two  i did give a second one and then bruner  and bentley ted's dogs  oh wow they're trained they have to wait  for the biscuits i gotta wait for the  biscuit then they give me cash  so wait a second what you're telling me  is they're buying the biscuits yes  how do they go to the atm everything's  going up these days is going up we'll  get back to you  have a great night  [Music]